i think my microphone all right
i just say um you need to stop
paying for y'all oh charlie
charlie got a bit too turned up at
elizabeth and andre's wedding and
no one could turn him down get you
together don't come to america
and try to
live on my dad elizabeth's sister jen
was just
sitting there recording the entire time
and her dad chuck
didn't know what to do with his son
believe it or not
this entire situation
it gets worse
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
the latest episode of happily ever after
was
juicy we got two weddings elizabeth and
andre tied the knot
once again this time in moldova and
angela and michael
finally said i do i know me and michael
have some hurdles in our future
but damn it i just got married so
tonight i just want to spend some
newlywed
time with my husband i just hope
michael's ready for this
[Laughter]
i cannot angela i can't alright well
on the flip side after kalani revealed
she's considering a divorce
from asuelu they brought both of their
families together for the first time
following all of the drama that went
down during their vacation
to washington i'm sorry clanny
i'm sorry for everything
[Music]
as usual i'm going to give you the
details on these
must-see moments kicking it off with
charlie
and what led up to his outburst not
elizabeth and andre's wedding
the entire family started their day off
on
a really good note andre and elizabeth
had a traditional ceremony
at the church and everyone was happy and
showing love
as they headed to the reception come on
don't walk
fast you guys look great they're great
there were even a few moments inside
where
charlie and chuck were bonding with
andre
as if they never had any issues
[Music]
those dancers
it seemed like everyone was enjoying
themselves
and i'm sure you've noticed this wedding
is nice
and i mean nice nice they had
tons of food a live band with a singer
and these high quality moldovan dancers
now while all of this is pretty
impressive
elizabeth's sister jyn shared her take
on the ceremony
and it kind of makes you look at the
glitz and glam of
it all a bit differently andre and
libby's wedding is so
over the top the way that they were
describing this reception
was that it was going to kind of be
low-key and everything and then we walk
in and it's like oh
like this is where all the money has
gone that my dad has given them
i feel like andre is trying to impress
everyone here back in moldova like look
what i have now look what i have and
it's like
you don't we do our family does but like
you don't as you could see charlie was
taking it to the head and eventually
his true feelings about this wedding
started to come out
little by little i think it was
uh expensive like
and it's like um my dad
has like seven kids so it's like um
did you do this for every other kid no
you didn't
so you know it's like why are you doing
this for him
like why why unfortunately
it seems like charlie has been trying to
drink away these fillings
all night which was a bit hard to watch
i think he's forgetting that his dad is
not doing this for andre
he's doing it for elizabeth chuck
revealed in the past
that he would do anything to see his
daughter smile
you remember all elizabeth had to do to
get him to pay for this wedding
was cry so while charlie and jen were so
concerned about how much this wedding
cost
chuck he was talking about how much he
loved the dancers
i've never been to a wedding reception
that they bring out
dancers and they like go crazy
and it's almost like a show like they
know how to party
well as the party went on charlie wasn't
eating as much
because he's not very fond of moldovan
food
so his liquid courage started to build
up
more and more leading to his
first his first outburst
it's in a wedding it's a show yeah
they've like uh
coordinated everything i mean he could
be royalty in moldova
jen's face said it all
luckily the guests are predominantly
moldovan and
don't speak english but that still
doesn't take away how wild
this next moment was during a toast
chuck had a really nice message for
andre
saying he's family now and he loves him
but then charlie took the mic and said
this don't ask my dad
okay okay just give it to my next one
no come to america
and think about microphones
[Applause]
as you probably assumed after the toast
was over
andre went looking for charlie who
happened to be jamming out on the dance
[Music]
floor
come here
here listen you trying to fight me in my
dover
well we just have to wait until next
week to see
what goes down is andre going to control
himself
or not all right moving on to
angela and michael these two had a
pretty smooth ceremony
and a really nice reception
today was one of the most happiest days
that i've ever seen
angela and truly believe that they do
both love each other
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been a journey for angela and
michael so
it was great to see them enjoy their day
but later on that night angela got a
terrifying call
about her mom being unresponsive and in
the icu
it's driving me crazy i wish i could
leave tonight but i can't
it's upsetting that i can't go
so i'm trying to get a plane to get to
the states because we don't know the
condition of my mother
and all i know is um
she can not be there when i get back
i can only imagine how horrible that
felt
i'm definitely continuing to send a lot
of love to angela
and her family now on to our final
highlight
asuelu's mom apologized to kalani after
accusing her
of being the reason asuelu wouldn't give
the thousand dollars
kalani also apologized to his mom for
the part she played in all of the drama
but it's a swallow sister tammy who
still doesn't want to make amends are
you agree with that
tammy i'm not gonna be apologize to
kalani about everything that happened in
washington
i don't have anything wrong that i said
i don't think kalani is
good for us well i want them to get
divorced and everything
well based off of the tease for next
week divorce still might be in the car
it's for asuelu and kalani also just
been going out
and lying about where he is so i had a
tracker on his phone
i need to protect my kids i can't keep
letting him do whatever the hell he
wants
i just want you to be happy and you're
not i'll support you obviously in
anything you do
all right 90 day fans fam i told you
this episode
was a lot but i appreciate you for
sticking with me
all the way through make sure you stick
with et to stay updated on all the
latest news from
our guilty pleasure i'll see you next
[Music]
time
you